Bonjour à vous, curieuses et curieux !
Et surtout à toi Emma
qui est arrivée ici par hasard.
Alors le défi du jour :
Faire bouger un objet à distance,
sans le toucher,
sans souffler dessus,
sans aimant et sans moteur.
Non, je ne suis pas le dernier Jedi
Il s'agit d'une recherche très sérieuse de l'Institut des sciences moléculaires de Bordeaux.
Alors déjà non !
Les chercheurs ne tentent pas
de faire bouger des rochers ni des tasses,
mais de petits objets de quelques millimètres de long,
des bandelettes de polymères,
un genre de plastique un peu spécial.
Regardez !
Impressionné ?
Attendez.
Franchement ?
On dirait pas une chenille qui fait du moonwalk ?
Ce n'est pas le pouvoir de la musique
qui donne vie à ce petit bout de plastique.
La technique utilisée s'appelle "électrochimie bipolaire".
Un terme que vous pouvez désormais placer en soirée.
Le principe ressemble à celui de la pile,
où une réaction chimique va créer un courant électrique.
Sauf que dans notre cas c'est l'inverse.
Un courant électrique va produire des
réactions chimiques sur l'objet.
Revenons à notre polymère danseur.
Vous l'aurez compris,
c'est un polymère qui a des propriétés
un peu particulières.
D'une part, il conduit l'électricité.
Ce qui est assez surprenant pour un plastique.
Et d'autre part,
il a été façonné pour que chacune des faces
réagisse différemment au courant électrique.
La face du bas est plus rugueuse que la face du haut.
Elle sera donc le siège de plus de réactions chimiques.
Et du coup elle se déformera davantage.
En se gonflant et en se dégonflant, elle va tordre l'objet.
Et en jouant sur la courbure des extrémités
et le courant appliqué, on arrive à le faire danser.
Voilà !
C'est la première fois que
des chercheurs réussissent à contrôler
le mouvement d'un polymère sans connexion physique.
Sans câble, quoi.
Alors oui, je vois poindre votre question.
En effet, ce petit bout de plastique
ne se balade pas, comme ça, tout seul.
En fait,
il baigne dans un milieu aqueux,
qui permet de conduire l'électricité
qui est appliquée sur les bords de la cuve.
Et figurez-vous,
que ce milieu pourrait être comparable au
liquide présent dans le corps humain.
Vous me voyez venir ?
Et oui !
A partir du mouvement de ce petit polymère,
il est possible d'imaginer de nombreux
dispositifs bio-médicaux, tels que...
... les muscles artificiels.
Costaud comme découverte !
Eh ! Psitt !
Abonnez-vous !